finnland das direkt an russland grenzt
jetzt will ihre regierung auch deutlich
weniger visa für russische touristen aus
stellen auch andere europäische länder
fordern dass weil putin im eigenen land
immer noch große unterstützung für
seinen krieg gegen die ukraine bekommt
der deutsche bundeskanzler will dabei
nicht mitziehen will visa für russen
nicht einschränken und so können sie
weiter in baden-baden urlaub machen
genauso wie an der côte d'azur während
ihr präsident die ukraine bombardiert
krieg hin oder her auch russen brauchen
urlaub gern machen russen traditionell
auf der 2014 annektierten kriterien doch
seit letzter woche herrscht auch hier
ausnahmezustand krieg im ferienparadies
die folge eine massenflucht russischer
urlauber doch wohin schampus luxus
cabrio das finden urlaubsreife russen
mit ordentlich kleingeld gleich an
mehreren orten in europa ob in baden
baden in deutschland am goldstrand in
bulgarien auf zypern sound tropez cannes
in griechenland auf mykonos oder in
bodrum in der türkei das sind die
beliebtesten urlaubsziele von putins
bürgern
baden baden ist traditionell beliebt bei
russen und so mancher besonders reiche
hat sich sogar eine villa hier gekauft
die geschäftswelt des ortes hat sich auf
die verwöhnte kundschaft eingestellt es
gibt sogar einen makler für russische
kunden doch nicht bei allen sind die
russen erwünscht
das ist kein vergnügen für mich ich
fühle mich deshalb unwohl
ich gehe ihnen aus dem weg ich mag sie
nicht deshalb vermeiden
auch die côte d'azur ist bei russen
angesagt insbesondere sound tropez und
cannes nicht nur lockt alljährlich ein
glamouröses filmfestival der
französischen nobelort bietet auch genug
tiefgang für luxusyachten der
superlative doch schon längst liegen
nicht mehr alle yachten in dem
idyllischen hafenbecken
er spricht sehr viel zu teuer geworden
dass ab dem 10 trotz kriegsausbruch
tummeln sich auch weiterhin in bodrum an
der türkischen küste viele russische
touristen nicht nur weil man dort mit
russischen rubeln bezahlen kann sondern
auch weil ihre luxus yachten dort
überwiegend ungehindert vorfahren können
zwar rechnen tourismus experten mit
einem rückgang von rund 50 prozent aber
bis zu 1,7 millionen russen dürften
immer noch das sonnenbad an der
türkischen ägäis genießen
bodrum baden-baden und die côte d'azur
genau dorthin haben wir auch unsere
reporter geschickt jörg völkerling peter
l und peter thelen deutschland an den
baden baden bei jörg völkerling jörg
baden-baden ja traditionell schon zu
zarenzeiten ein kurort der russen wie
lebt es sich aktuell als große dort
die schwierigkeit ist erstmal überhaupt
hierherzukommen es gelten längst nicht
mehr die goldenen zeiten runter jetzt
geht er sein geld im kasino vorspielen
konnte sogar den ehering jetzt müssen
die russen die hier noch urlaub machen
wollen dann den hügeln des schwarzwaldes
tricks suchen sie müssen sich von
privaten ärzten einladen lassen auf
ärztliche empfehlung ist es noch möglich
herzukommen und müssen dann über
flughafen wie helsinki einen weg hierher
suchen makler haben früher 70 prozent
ihres umsatzes mit rosen gemacht sie
haben auch viele wirklich
herrschaftliche anwesen hier in
baden-baden gekauft wie zum beispiel
auch das anwesen hinter mir das anwesen
maria halten das einst dem elektronik-
pioniere max grundig gehörte und zuletzt
in der hand eines ukrainischen
oligarchen mit russischem pass war aber
seit 22 jahren eigentlich hier vor sich
hin rotten einem wirklich
bedauernswerten zustand ist der damalige
inhaber konnte wohl zuletzt nicht mehr
seine stromrechnung von 20.000 euro
bezahlen so ähnlich ist es auch einem
hotel in der innenstadt ergangen er
musste die stadt baden-baden not
sicherungsmaßnahmen erreichen einrichten
womit das haus nicht auf die straße
fällt und wenn man jetzt durch die
straßen von baden-baden verliert dann
trifft man eher auf ukrainischer
touristen die die nase rümpfen über die
letzten russen die hier noch sind es
sind immer noch 2200 russische einwohner
die in der stadt leben allerdings mit
festen wohnsitz und die früheren klingen
bringt touristen die sieht man hier
eigentlich immer seltener also dass
jetzt jemand der mit champagner und
kaviar an den lokalen medien rizzi
sitzen würde und sein geld verprasst
dieses bild findet man so hier nicht
mehr da gehen wir weiter vielen dank an
die côte d'azur nach kann dort wo die
großen yachten normalerweise liegen
peter hell ist dort aber wegen der eu
sanktionen dürften ja zumindest die
reichen oligarchen die putin freunde die
auf der schwarzen liste stehen ihre
yachten dort nicht mehr parken ansonsten
würden sie beschlagnahmen oder
das ist absolut korrekt hier in cannes
herrscht wirklich bonjour tristesse für
die russen ich will dass einmal ganz
kurz zeigen wir sehen hier die
superyachten die normalerweise hier
stehen es stehen auch welche da aber es
sind lücken da hier kommt gerade auch so
einen riesenpot wieder rein
normalerweise stehen da aber auch die
russischen yachten und man sieht das
dann wirklich lücken sind die sind weg
die sind seit diesen sanktionen weg wir
haben hier sehr prominente gesellschaft
hinter mir rechts ist das riesen boot
von 40 millionen euro von berlusconi dem
sohn von silvio berlusconi im ehemaligen
regierungschef von italien und wenn wir
uns nochmal einmal ganz umdrehen dann
sehen wir hinten die superyacht von
prinz mohammed al fateh 110 millionen
dollar das ist ein mitglied der
saudischen königsfamilie also das ist so
die preisklasse die herumfährt die
russen fehlen sie fehlen warum erstens
wegen der sanktionen zweitens es gibt
keine direktflüge mehr hier richtung
kann bzw nach nizza das heißt sie
bleiben im prinzip alle in istanbul
stecken oder in der türkei wir waren
vorhinein kapferer auch einem wirklich
tollen luxus ort wo normalerweise sehr
viel russen sind in einem französischen
restaurant das normalerweise auch mit
russen besetzt ist der
restaurantbesitzer hat gesagt hier ist
kein bus mehr wenn überhaupt dann
ukraine oder menschen aus kasachstan
aber die russen kommen nicht und die
bedauern dass hier natürlich die
geschäftsleute weil sie sagen naja die
bringen auch viel geld und seit der
krieg da ist schlummert ist also ein
bisschen in den kassen da hält sich das
mitleid ein bisschen den grenzen mehr
hat ein kellner erzielt das manchmal an
mittagstischen da einige tausend dollar
fester vergessen werden also ich wollte
verfassen aber es ist so mit champagner
und hunger und auch abramowitsch war
dort in diesem restaurant also die
zeiten sind vorbei und das ist noch ein
bisschen freudig und auch freudig dass
die russen weg sind einige sagen wir
wollen sie hier nicht haben aber die
geschäftswelt sagt natürlich gleich die
bringen auch viel geld in die kasse
dafür haben sie jetzt viel aber die das
ganze geld hier in diesen luxus shops
ausgeben und die leute hoffen natürlich
dass sich das bald ändern wird nur das
sieht nicht so aus wie russen werden
vermutlich die ganze saison nicht
hinkommen und wahrscheinlich es ist ja
auch nicht bitten kann und wo sind sie
hin die russen zu peter tiede nach
bodrum mit ihren jachten peter
meyer j den namen abramowitsch gehört
haben hinter mir das ist so lasst uns
einen super jagten von roman
abramowitsch im demo dinge die man auch
im westen und einmal war israelischer
stadt mit dem portugiesischen staat
bürger immer versucht im westen fuß zu
fassen fc chelsea hatten gehören muss er
jetzt sonst verkaufen wäre ja nicht nur
wie solange sondern auch andere hatten
wir kennen es ist
jahren hat er hier in die region bonn
rom gebracht manchmal ist das ist ein
typisches
und solche boote sind jetzt hier und im
standen unseren baden-baden ich sag mal
russen genau gebraucht
sondern wir haben richtig richtig viele
also ganz herzlichen dank an unsere
reporter auf den spuren der russischen
touristen jörg völkerling in baden-baden
peter hellenen kann und peter tiede auf
dem wasser vor bodrum vielen dank
[Musik]